now that putin's plan a has founded he
is already escalating by intensifying
his attacks on civilians maternity wards
schools and homes have been bombed
without any regard in life
families are being starved out in
freezing basement shelters and targeted
as they flee
the united kingdom
and our allies in nato and the g7 here
today
are clear
we will not stand by
while putin vents his fury
on ukraine
i've rarely seen
our
nations
more united in recent years
than we are now
putin's failure in ukraine
is vital
for the peace and prosperity of all of
us
and his barbaric invasion has galvanized
the international community into
collective action
we will work with like-minded allies to
ramp up lethal aid to ukraine at scale
providing kit
to president zielinski in in the
quantity and with the quality that he
needs to defend his country
from its bullying neighbor
today i've announced that we in the uk
will send an additional six thousand
missiles and provide twenty five million
pounds in unrestricted funding for
ukraine's armed forces more than
doubling the lethal aid we've provided
to date
we're bolstering our support for the
nato countries on the front line
sending a new deployment of uk troops to
bulgaria on top of doubling our troops
both in poland and in estonia
this is just the beginning
we must support a free and democratic
ukraine
in the long term this is a fellow
european democracy
fighting a war of national defense
nato and g7 leaders were also united
today in our determination to continue
turning the screws on the kremlin's war
machine including by weaning ourselves
off russian oil and gas
and reshaping global energy security
the uk has already hit
over over a thousand russian individuals
and entities in our toughest ever
sanctions
and the foreign secretary
has announced 65 new sanctions against
russian banks weapons manufacturers and
oligarchs just this morning i also
discussed the humanitarian response with
our allies and partners today as we
continue to see huge numbers of
ukrainians flee their homes
and the message
that president putin can take from
today's extraordinary meeting of nato
and the g7 is this
ukraine
is not alone
we stand
with the people
of kiev
of mario paul of lev
and donetsk
and
as president zalensky has said himself
the people of ukraine will prevail
and putin
must fail and he will fail thank you all
very much and i'm going to take
a few questions from
as many of you as i as i can though we
have to rush for a for a plane sam coats
of sky
thank you promises sound coasters
um president zielinski interestingly
didn't repeat his call for us uh no-fly
zone when he addressed nato leaders
instead he was very very specific he
wants tanks and jets
our nato members
are is the united kingdom going to give
him tanks and jets and if not why not
uh thanks sam he did he did indeed uh
call for for tanks and there's a there's
a particular reason for that to what uh
uh what president zielenski wants is to
try to uh relieve mario paul uh and and
to he and to help uh the the thousands
of ukrainian fighters uh in the city uh
to that end he does need armor as he
sees it uh we're looking at what we can
do to help but i got to tell you uh
logistically at the moment it looks very
difficult for both with armor and with
uh with jets uh
we're very conscious of what he's asking
for at the moment uh we're looking at
the the the equipment that we think is
more immediately valuable is uh is uh
missiles
that will enable the ukrainians to
protect themselves against bombardment
from the air
but also to deal with the uh the grad
rocket launchers uh the uh the the
russian heavy artillery uh that is doing
such uh death and dealing such death and
destruction in the cities and there i
think if we can uh really help them uh
that would be extremely valuable because
they need protection from that
absolutely merciless uh onslaught from
uh from artillery and from and from the
rocket launchers